in this new house you got another parrot
no not a parrot it's a macaw
which I totally know the difference is
this like the latest late one yes it's a
parrot it's a big ass parrot
hey
look I made the lady lady cup
here it goes oh yeah dude that's dude
yeah he's boy he's a biting son look you
I made him cover my gosh oh here you
[Applause]
I always wanted one and my kids bought
this from a for my birthday and so I
said I'm gonna name him the dude I
thought that was so cool so it's the
dude so we go off come back we go pick
up the dude and they went uh Miss
Bradshaw we sext the dude and it's the
female oh but he but he knows his name
as the dude
so it's the dude it's a female
the dude and so yep if I get to come
back on the show I'll bring you a
picture of peanuts is that what's the
second one the second one girl boy so
kind of the dude yeah the dude is a
female and Peanut's male
and uh right now the the dude can't
stand peanut but I think I think when
nature takes its course they'll be
getting along just fine
I didn't know so McCall you need if you
get another one name at McGraw after Tim
because come on Tim McGraw yeah McGraw
well I want to tell you I got another
one you do I got an African gray they
are some talking Jessies oh I saw it in
I saw it out of the nest it just took it
out of the nest Kelly I'm telling you I
just melted oh and the guy the guy knows
me he's sucker he's sticking it to me I
paid 10 grand for that bird
and he goes well I paid 10 grand for
peanut yeah peanut peanut probably costs
500 anywhere else I got 10 grand out of
me but I saw I saw this bird I went I
gotta have that bird and he says I'm
saving him for you he's special
yeah I don't know what do you call I
bought him but I don't know what I paid
for him had no idea so I come home just
don't look yeah so we come home my
wife's thinking Tammy she goes
I got a name for the African gray okay I
said well we've got peanut we got to do
what you got she said Steve
name a bird
why why this dumbass bird's name is
Steve
why did she go my wife is extremely
intelligent and I just think when people
walk in the house and peanuts hollering
and the dudes hollering it would be nice
to have someone named Steve Steve yeah
so the bird's name is
see I actually if I get to come on again
I'll bring Steve I'll bring Steve okay
and if you have another one McGraw
McGraw
when when when the dude Tim McGraw you
like Tim McGraw I just like the name I
like him too McCall McGraw when the dude
and peanut get together
and have babies Tim McCall yeah
thank you I'm getting again getting it
you are so short
by the by the end of this you're gonna
have a damn bird named Tim McCall yeah
oh for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]